and if you're looking forward to a
parade coming up in
Denver when is
parade when is parade
Thursday
no I need to go
home okay got and on the other end how
would you rate your defense
tonight you tell me man I'm going know
something about you wa how would you
rate my defense tonight be honest
there's no wrong answers beest be Hest I
can accept that you know Kevin uh that
was talk about about you coming back for
the playoffs last year so you really
just been working on your game trying to
get back your timing and condition
really be to be honest correct
yeah uh the overall you talk about
growth the growth with Brandon Clark and
jiren's defensive games uh y'all's as a
trio a big where are you from bro oh I'm
I'm from Tennessee
oh that's a sick accent bro I haven't
heard that before that's awesome dude
that's sick I I appreciate the kind I'm
a fan of yours as well I appreciate the
kind words thank you sir so if you get a
win tonight that'll breed confidence
going into those next four games against
teams in the similar spots beside you in
the table where you from Jim Ireland I
like your accent it's tough I want to
learn how to talk like that but ask your
question again I was too much listening
to your accent
amen at the end of the Minnesota game
you said let the ball come to me cuz I
know I'm going to make it was that the
same feeling tonight Cole yeah
yeah yeah come on yeah last question of
the
night who is a better color commentator
Dell Curry or Michael Thompson and it's
one guy's birthday today so oh it's your
Po's birthday I'm not saying names
respect happy birthday to to pop po Papa
Thompson uh I got to go Dale Curry
though oh my oh man what's wrong
with he's out he's walking off yeah
thank you follow uh Cuban just walked by
and was chanting MVP towards you boban
how did that make you feel oh feel
amazing you know first time on TV hi Mom
hi Dad Hi family I'm here in Dallas it
has been a delight to have you on our
show inside the NBA B before we let you
go I got to hear it you rang you rang
yeah
I love I love you
B I love you bobad thank you brother
yeah thank you so much and thank you
guys because choose me and not Luka
first time okay this what movies is made
of this is what movies this is what
movies is made of four months away I
come back to free throws don't worry
about it I got
that uh played basketball for a long
time so um if I okay I won't say that I
W did it word after I'm up I'm damn
mother Dam mother get get off me awesome
there was a play where you were kind of
running down the sideline chasing down a
loose ball and got thrown into the front
row um bunch of drinks got spilled I
think uh seem like the bench kind of
enjoyed that I'm curious kind of what
they said to you when you walk back over
there oh asked Bron if that was his
Lobos over there cuz this it smell
horrible oh but uh I'm an investor bro
what you that don't mean it don't taste
good uh so again two decades in the game
is there I've been asking all the
teammates that come over here about
their favorite LeBron play in those 20
years I want you to tell me yours but
before you tell me yours yeah I asked
Pat be what's his favorite LeBron
highight over the last 20 this fool he
going to say the block ey had on
the yo yo man what's wrong with Pat
man what's wrong with Pat man his
highlight what's wrong with Pat man Pat
got a problem man he got issues last
time a rocket had back-to-back 43o games
was back in 1982 Moses Malone I wasn't
even born there rest in peace I wasn't
even born there though um you know Hall
of Famer but you got your rhythm going
now thanks James thank you followell
Luca it's never been done in NBA history
a 60 point 20 rebound triple double 60
points 20 boards never never happened
baby how's it feel right now I'm tired
as
hell you can rest later you're young I
need a recovery beer what differentiates
you when the defense is right there in
your face and you still hit those tough
shots um you know my teammates have
confidence in me I work on those shots
every day and you know it just went down
tonight I was able to knock it down all
right thank you why we've got to go
thank you one all right that was great
wait you want more questions no I'm good
I'm good with
one all right guys kawhai Jonathan show
di TV if the Raptors win the NBA title
what do you think this will mean for
Canada and the Toronto Raptors you've
already won with the San Antonio Spurs
you've seen the way it impacted that
Community what do you think this will do
for
Canada um I'm really not sure um I guess
you really have to ask somebody on the
street or one of our fans so Oscar yeah
they went Oscar so this is a Oscar
worthy script for Last Dance for my last
season um I couldn't have asked for
anything more obviously people say yeah
I asked to get the playoffs and all that
welcome back
[Applause]
LeBron kiss soft he's soft he's not he's
not even in my league like nowhere near
me um and if if I was their coach I
would I would never put him on me ever
again he he's like no put somebody else
on me because I'm I'm a t every time we
play he's
[Applause]
trash I guess that says it
all Desmond
clearly tonight you used impressive
dribbling skills to successfully uh fake
out your opponents multiple times and um
in the second second quarter you made a
jump shot where your body was turned
like 180° away from the basket it was
just an amazing shot you're always
making these spectacular moves with just
within a split second um do you
anticipate doing them or is it just a
second nature to you like do you just
not even have to think about it um you
know the way you explain it you need to
be around more often I I I I you know I
just try to go out and do the best the
best way I can you get another triple
double perfect perfect from the field
perfect from the free throw line the
first player ever to do that thoughts on
that Ah that's pretty interesting uh
Russell things got a little contingence
between you and and uh Patrick Beverly
can you talk about you know kind of what
happened there oh yeah he was talking
about he was first team all defense but
I I I didn't know what the hell he was
talking about cuz I had 42 at the time
um the series you know I don't know what
he talking about maybe he was dreaming
of some I don't know sorry excuse
my cuss word but I don't know what he
was talking about but I guess he he
wanted to be first defense or something
maybe he was dreaming about it but now
it shocked me because he said he looked
up and said no what can gar you I got 40
points I'm like that's nice he took 34
shots to get
it I mean no I'm not trying to I'm not
trying to bash anybody but I mean you
know men lie women lie but the numbers
don't I mean I mean he's Kevin
Durant I promise we
tried we didn't roll over and we didn't
just say man you know what just come on
give us 50 tonight of course not you
know he's a hell of a player the shots
he took you know he made some tough
shots if you was a coach what would you
tell us to
do thank you to take to we tried
everything so we we we tried everything
we had we had several different
coverages for KD and they didn't work we
um why is Kelly so good at putback
dunks uh freak athlete
but he's got a great eye for the timing
of it
and um know you can jump that high and
you're looking for those opportunities
then you know good things happen so he
makes it look really good though I will
say that he makes it look really good uh
What happened on that go bear Kur fuffle
at at the end that is a word right there
I what you
sayu great job bro that's strong toward
the end of the game uh you shot a three
kind of putting the dagger into him and
you look toward the crowd toward uh
Rihanna uh was was that um on purpose or
or do you remember that or I don't even
remember that well just let you know
social media is buzzing about really yes
don't get in that trap yeah don't get in
there
I'm cool have fun with that our Joker
sha here first of all SI Ana igra
BR uh and what is it going to take you
to go into uh Portland and win game
three no there's nothing wrong with your
headset that's just see IA
BR ah yeah thank you
man and now you are an NBA champion Nia
how does that feel it's good it's good
the job is down we can go home now
congratulations